Côte d'Ivoire
gagné nous sommes très très très heureux
aujourd'hui parce que la Côte d'Ivoire
vient de rehausser son niveau c'est un
mental de faire imaginez-vous jouer à 10
prendre un but je veux dire au cours de
match égaliser et gagner le match en
cous de match c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment incroyable on aurait dû gagner
ça céit un match qui était fait pour le
Mali mais malheureusement on va dire le
football c'est comme ça c'est un jeu et
ça arrive c'est le miracle permanent le
miracle permanent le miracle permanent
que Dieu bénisse notre République que
Dieu bénisse la Côte d'Ivoire on
reviendra plus fort l'année prochaine on
a une très bonne équipe de la Côte
d'Ivoire et on part jusqu'à la finale
voil remporter la finale